hi I'm Jen and I'm Ricky and welcome to
the best of BuzzFeed how do you do this
is so hard we are going to still do the
things that we do every day
masturbate no we are not [ __ ] doing
that
oh yeah
that's very funny we just watched some
of the funniest clips from the past two
weeks of BuzzFeed and I think we're
gonna watch some more we're gonna bring
in some familiar faces that you might
recognize then that come along gonna be
one hell of a time so Ricky and I are
producers here which means that we like
edit and craft a lot of the videos you
see and we sort of want to know what you
guys think yeah a lot of people actually
think that we don't read the comments
but we do oh we do and then I cry myself
to sleep yeah you want to read the first
comment yes coming from so our first
comment this is a comment from the video
stuff your cat does that would be rude
for your roommate to do
it's from the username oh by Z ins I was
gonna make a chemistry joke but all the
good ones are gone it's a pun someone
made a chemistry pun
does anyone know what our garden element
well what kind of element again oh my
god
alright oh I get it you get the joke is
I was gonna make a chemist a joke but
all the good ones are a gas regardless
you know what's important we know it's a
pun the person that made this comment
ruin my life yeah this is actually from
the video I made called people who are
afraid of bees to play with bees and
this comes from is the user John
Glasscock oh no you tell me again next
video people who are afraid of drowning
drink water fifty a get up folks good
word gold blast-off's okay all jokes
aside great funny comment he's kind of
making fun of us fair enough I actually
do it people who are afraid of drowning
drink water I make another fear yeah and
quenching their thirst oh wow
alright I want to check out the next
comment please hit me with the next
comment this is from a video called of a
hi guys decorate cakes and this comes
from toast
whoever toast is is so committed to
toast this is an avatars toast and his
name is toast I want Chris to smear
frosting on my juicy book I love it I
love it this guy's got this is toast god
I just see toast like scrolling the
interview like god there's got to be a
good toast comment for me today and then
he stumbled upon cakes he's like
psoriasis me and then you put up without
him barely put that frosting on my toast
Chris yeah alright well I think that's
enough comments for now we got some
other cool stuff to do begin a cool [ __ ]
did you know that this actually isn't
immune Jen's apartment this is a
BuzzFeed set check it out oh my god
movie magic we don't actually even live
together yeah
what what's next on the agenda we're
going to go meet a BuzzFeed producers
we're gonna pick the brain okay let's go
oh good let's go boys good and Ricky I
have a pretty short whoa hey this is
Caroline she makes all the cool nifty
videos that you like on Facebook yeah hi
Karen cool so uh listen they're shooting
laundry through the ages right now what
age is this I am the 18th century okay
when no one got laid apparently Wow hey
hey do you want to come back to our
house and watching clips okay all right
okay so welcome to our lovely abode EQ
Sophia in your opinion what's the
craziest BuzzFeed video that you've ever
made one time I made a video about auras
with like a semi crazy person I did also
make lady like eat beauty products here
those are fun yeah I mean yeah this one
however is the craziest the craziest
video
we have a box of unopened pads from 1975
it's a little like erotic filtered way
like it has a hand on my vagina you're
in it we keep we do confirm this is the
sexiest we've ever looked it's crazy to
think how period technology has improved
literally in the last like few years
versus like all of female history should
point out it I do love the phrase period
technology why did you make this video
there's no like handbook for like the
best thing for your body you and I mean
so you really have to rely on like other
women's experiences so this is cool
because like you're kind of taking part
in writing a handbook for a newer
generation if you yes though if I were
to recommend a book the care and keeping
of you such a relevant book yeah the
care and keeping of you I mean have our
diverse cover how well did this video do
so oh this video got I think 2.8 million
views in one week
that's amazing mind of was a perfect
storm of like lady like Ingrid Nilsen
and periods man because we want to talk
about periods so before we go into the
next section song we just want to show
you a fun cute little clip of you when
you were a baby in turn oh no
and we thought it'd be fun to revisit
it's when you were in the Charlie
Charlie video I know what this is
I am so superstitious I don't know why
I'm doing this
Charlie Charlie can we play Charlie
Charlie will you appear
he appeared right next to you what I'm
Charlie hi no not physically oh my god
my god my god I got big job I'm not
gonna own up that is actually exactly
what I thought I did think he was
possessed for about a half a second why
I consider myself an intelligent person
but that was not my you know brightest
moment well thank you for sharing your
intimate path with us
so at BuzzFeed we also love to make food
videos aka KAC so we're going to watch
the top tasty videos of the past couple
weeks with a hi guy
all right let's bring out Brandon from
the hi guys hey what's up Brandon
good come on come take a seat all right
ah all right let's watch some tasty
videos upside-down banana cake upside
down oh right banana that pretty yellow
color that looks like I'm gonna feel
like I want to just rub that that stuff
looks like you can go on my belly on top
and inside okay wow that looks great
cinnamon what the hell was caramel see I
like caramel because I'm the same colors
caramel oh my god a caramel man
exactly oh Jesus Christ oh my god that's
beautiful this is the cake of gods
banana gods oh my god whoa that looks
beautiful it does oh my god wait wait
pause this for a second it's we just
admire this beauty what an ice cream
come from ah lots of ice cream ice cream
oh and melting that was too sexual tasty
videos are like there's like a weird
sexual element sometimes what's called
food porn for a reason oh that's right
yeah dude tasty the finest in food parts
the outfit food porn is like regular
porn event bombs into moms hmm oh my god
oh that's so cute look it's like a baby
being delivered looks like a little
bow-wow garlic salt and pepper Italian
seasoning
you can get a quick piece of bones wait
a minute look at that sauce I want to
dip it in the sauce yeah the what is
that is that cocktail dessert
marinara oh yeah I could definitely eat
30 of those we're gonna show you the
food but you can't eat it okay Brandon
so we're not cruel enough that we're
going to show you a bunch of food videos
without feeding you some awesome food
hey man you're beautiful
you don't please eat everybody grab a
pizza bomb oh my god I thought you just
did you put the whole thing in her mouth
no one you ain't one already
tastes like cheese and blade it tastes
like wood you see these are so good it's
like my childhood wrapped up into one
little bun of Awesomeness mmm are these
carbs in eagerness okay
the ultimate test is like the the
glamour shot at the end right ooh I
thought so my slo-mo that slo-mo that
shirt you see you can see I already a
bet that's how I eat hot wings at a
strip club right down the middle
so that's it for our show we hope you
enjoy
it yeah Brandon Sofia thanks for coming
by thanks for having us thank you thank
you thank you so we'll see you around
next time yeah
thanks everybody John Glasgow who's not
you'll find out you'll see